hey youtubers is Charlie and some new
details have come out about Star Wars
Episode seven just like those leaked
Tatooine pictures it's mostly about the
main Luke Skywalker type character or
the character that's going to get Luke
Skywalker's arc from the original
trilogy you know introduce us to this
new Star Wars universe there's also a
few new details about some classic
characters that are coming back but if
you're finding me for the first time I'm
just doing Star Wars bonus videos until
rebels gets here in the fall be sure to
subscribe to get everything feel free to
leave me suggestions for any you know
bonus videos or topics that you want to
talk about specifically so the most
important stuff john boyega's character
is supposed to be the person the story
uses to introduce us to the new JJ
Abrams Disney Star Wars universe he's
getting that Luke Skywalker character
arc or something similar to that so what
does that mean well you remember back in
episode 4 where Luke Skywalker was
living in the middle of nowhere Tatooine
barely knew anything about the Galactic
Civil War only had passing knowledge of
the Empire and the rebellion and
definitely was not a Jedi yet that's
supposed to be john boyega's character
just a totally normal kid who gets swept
up into this big galaxy he was part of
that group of people filming early
scenes on those Tatooine sets a couple
of weeks ago so at the very least it
confirms a few things
the rumors are is that his character
development will be very similar to Luke
Skywalker's so he's not gonna be a Jedi
or even a Padawan at the beginning but
he'll slowly develop as the sequels come
as for actual Jedi we don't know exactly
what some of the other characters are
playing but we do know that Luke
Skywalker is in the movie as a real-life
person he's been growing his obi-wan
Kenobi Jedi beard so he's probably going
to be the spiritual leader at least for
the good guys in the movie because of
the similar character arc with john
boyega's character I'm thinking that
Luke Skywalker himself might follow a
modified version of Obi Wan's character
arc in the original trilogy so you kind
of see what JJ Abrams and Disney are
doing they're honoring those classic
films by using the same film camera
they're not doing digital they're using
real-life creatures in the same sets and
they're gonna follow some of the same
character beets I don't expect them to
just cut and paste the plot but a really
safe way to appease superfans would be
to do a Battlestar Gallactica thing
where all the characters realize that
all these things have happened before
and they will happen again if you're not
familiar with the plot of Ronald D Moore
Battlestar Galactica feel free to ask
for clarification in the comments more
characters though
I have seen rumors about Lupita being
obi-wan Kenobi's granddaughter I think
it would be fine but it would be a huge
departure from the movie canon at no
point in any of George Lucas's films did
obi-wan have any kind of romance with
anyone so I would be really curious to
see where that granddaughter came from
but remember if JJ Abrams could reboot
the continuity of the Star Trek universe
he could do it in the Star Wars universe
too so prepare yourself for him to
change some of the story from the
original trilogy it might happen the
primary antagonist initially is supposed
to be a female Sethe character the best
theories I've seen since last week is
that it will be Gwendoline Christie it's
going to be a female and a main cast
member and how many women have they cast
in this movie so far practically none
aside from Leia and no I'm pretty sure
that Leia is not gonna be the Sith
Warrior in this movie but would that not
be crazy
I just keep remembering this interview
kwinda like Christie did at the
beginning of Game of Thrones season 4 or
she said she had to bite someone's ear
off in a scene and they just laughed at
how ridiculous and violent it was I'm
wondering if the Star Wars people saw
that and said hmmm she would make an
excellent Sith Warrior using a really
compelling female villain is something
that the Clone Wars did with asajj
ventress but think about episode 7 using
someone that's a closer analog to Darth
Vader
Gwendoline Christie does look like she's
about the same size as David Prowse he
was the guy that actually stepped into
that Darth Vader costume so it's totally
plausible that she could be that Sith
Warrior but I don't think they'd make
her wear mask even if they did want her
to be like a Darth Vader type character
speaking of villains if you remember the
original trilogy in the progression of
evil we started out with Darth Vader
being like the main villain in the first
movie in most of the second and then
they kind of introduced the emperor do
not be surprised if we don't find out
who the Sith master is until the second
Star Wars film just looking at the
casting sheet my eyes dart to max von
sydow
just because he looks like a villain but
that's kind of an obvious move so feel
free to suggest any other possibilities
they will cast more new people whenever
we get to the second film episode eight
so we might not even see this if masters
face in this first movie
the only other new things that we've
learned about the movie are that despite
it being 30 years after Return of the
Jedi there will be no new republic that
doesn't mean the Empire is still going
strong but the New Republic was
something that evolved in the expanded
universe so I'm not surprised that
they're not going to use it the last
thing is spin-off related so Boba Fett's
armor was spotted on set or Mandalorian
armor however we want to think about it
bobafet himself was not seen no
confirmation on what role he'll play in
the first film but he is in the new
trilogy it's likely that he'll just be
teased in that first film and then they
might use a post-credits scene with him
to tease the first spin-off Disney
hasn't confirmed what that first
spin-off is gonna be but don't be
surprised if they wait to tell us until
episode 7 comes out just to maintain a
certain element of surprise but because
Disney owns both Star Wars and Marvel
right now totally expect to get that
post-credits treatment where you tease
each next film at the end of the
previous film so let me know in the
comments what do you think about Brienne
becoming like a big new Darth Vader or
Sith Warrior and what do you think about
Lupita becoming obi wan's granddaughter
would you be upset that they're changing
the original canon I think I'd probably
be able to live with it it's happened to
so many other franchises that if they
think that it's gonna make the story
better then I want them to try it but JJ
Abrams has already fired Michael Arndt
the person who wrote that first draft of
Episode seven and he wasn't a bad writer
he was the guy who wrote Toy Story 3
which is actually a really good movie so
it sounds like they've been having a lot
of script problems in the last year so
whatever they end up deciding on
hopefully it's for the best
so my next Star Wars bonus video is
either gonna be plot related for episode
7 depending on what we learn in the next
week or it's just gonna be one of my
favorite expanded universe stories be
sure to subscribe to get it
oh actually I almost forgot Billy Dee
Williams confirmed that he's going to be
part of the new rebels cartoon as Lando
Calrissian he didn't say how many
episodes he's gonna be in but I'm
guessing that he's just gonna be a
recurring guest character so right now
click here to learn more about Star Wars
Episode 7 and click here to learn more
about Avengers 2 I'm actually working on
a special new video for that tonight
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys later
high fives
you